you're welcome to this video this is the
first video for this year's sinkfield
cap this is the third edition first one
yeah was in the 2013 and it's erm it's
been growing now a 10-player event and
it's part of this new I was it called
grand chest two are the second on
tournament in that and the series of
events yeah we know that in the first
event in Norway to Palo of one a bit
surprisingly and the Carlton had a very
bad result it was quite surprising to
see I think he it was three games if i'm
not mistaken and guided really was a bad
event for him so this is the the second
part of this this chest or and if a
Carlson wants to do something um he
really has to win it I mean everything
else is kind of unacceptable so this
game in the very first round pink cards
with white against Apollo was some
exceptionally important for the overall
yeah scheme of things so if this game
has a winner it will be quite quite um
yeah telling what what what happened in
this event so I'm going to concentrate
on that game and don't look at the other
games i'm going to do a game of the day
and really just one game i can give you
some brief information about the other
games but i won't look at and any any
moves and rather do this game a little
bit more thoroughly it was difficult by
the way to choose but i went for this
game ultimately because of the purely as
a sporting importance and just so
important because of the two players the
world champion and the guy leading the
overall event so let's see cars went
with 1.e4 as he does in his majority of
games which to be perfectly honest I
never really quite God because I always
thought that he's better off with with
d4c 493 but ok that's just my personal
take on things I'm not his coach so see
593 d6
he's scoring bed with badly with e4 just
that I always felt when he has something
else on I don't know I did felt better
to me I don't know okay he plays Bishop
b5 check that's his usual line it
doesn't play the open Sicilian much
these days he does but not not a lot
this check has served him very well over
the years to part of goes 497 editor the
sharpest move probably Bishop d7 is some
the prescribed mainline after which john
white normally takes and sets up a
maraca see bind which is very solid for
black but also somewhat unexcited if um
um yeah keep in mind this is not very
exciting and keep in mind what we get in
the game and then you see white apparel
of place 97 just the farm war fighting
move and this is within or this is the
spirit that he usually arrives that at
the body wants to get a fighting right
fighting position even with black yeah
carbon plays castles the drawback of 97
by the way is that it's somewhat hampers
plexus development yet as we see the
bishop cannot come out and so this
should be seven is somewhat more fluent
move it's it's a bit easier to play and
here you really get something unique and
quite quickly and specially hit this
game so castles Knight to f6 a text 34
pawn rook e1 and now went a six yeah
that's an interesting moment card will
now place the somewhat unconventional
looking move Bishop to d3 um you would
expect wide to go back to f1 but it
should be three has an idea what white
wants to do is he wants to ultimately
set up this typical classical center
with c3 and d4 and the question is where
to go where to put the bishop and you
can go to have one instead of Bishop d3
end and do that or what guards cards
until to d3 in order to later put it on
c2 yeah so let's just assume black
wouldn't do something specific what it
the game but let's just say it would
play something something slowish then
why it's a DM is something oops
something like that yeah to get that
full Center and have the bishop on c2
not on f1 yeah here you can sometimes go
to be three or maybe use it like after a
five to go to to e4 yeah it's a little
bit more active there may be in
comparison to f1 so that is the idea
drawback is it is rather slow Bishop on
d3 and at the part of the something
about it very quickly he goes with b5
and he took a moment for that for that
decision um not probably because he
didn't probably a think about this over
the board but he did just trying to
recollect his preparation um although he
could expect this to happen those first
couple of moves because this particular
position had been reached before in in
games and in also in a game by the world
champion by magnus carlsen um he now
played c4 as he did in 2013-14 I'm sorry
in the game against Hikaru Nakamura
funny enough um so there has been an
example game that T'Pol of could bases
preparation on cards and had that on the
board before in the game back then
Nakamura played 95 interesting choice
based on the fact that after the capture
that Bishop is hanging it's a bit a bit
strange to say but black definitely here
has a good position right probably um
yeah does not want to take cards
actually played Bishop back to everyone
that wasn't a bad position for black but
to pawn off now yeah came up with
something really outrageous he played
the move g5 that's a funny move right
would be very low on my list of moves to
consider I mean probably I wouldn't
consider it at all unless I am probably
would have done the same as was to ba
loved it before that game
looking at the computer because engines
give their move as one of the top
choices it looks very very strange I
have to have to admit but um well it is
a very modern chess and you look at the
moves really one by one move by move
does it work does it not and it looks
strange but it has got some some ideas
and some justifications we will see
Carlton actually takes that pawn but
sometimes when when the other side is
playing such and somewhat some wood real
movie are ignoring the center pushing a
flame on you sometimes and think okay
wait um I'm just going to ignore that
right I'm not going to play along with
his ideas and just develop things the
thing is that is not so easy in this
position if you just say let's say you
want to ignore that whole thing and you
play that same night c32 some developing
move then he goes chief one and this is
rather weird because the night has
absolutely no good square yeah each one
is blocked by the local d2 there's still
a pawn as white handset somewhat we had
peace configuration bishop only three in
front of the pawn there's as I said it's
a bit slow yeah you have you put the
bishop on that unnatural square that
anticipating that you will move the sea
pawn move the bishop again then move the
porn on the two it's slow yeah and here
white hits no square there you probably
have to go to something like this and
then 95 makes lots of sense all of a
sudden yeah that poor near is now very
safely protected and the night only five
has a strong position in the middle of
the board after something like that
retreat blank will take and this is
really crazy those two pawns they do an
excellent job of securing that night
yeah and night nh4 it's just looking
very silly that is just just not a good
position for what I mean 93 is not a
particularly great move i'm just showing
that white is yeah he has to do
something he cannot just ignore black
some blogs ideas he took on g5 i think
this is right an important thing to
consider is if you check the time
time is correct it is just off by a
couple of seconds cars are took 30
minutes for that move and this is quite
interesting because as as we already
have learned he had the position before
g5 already on the board yeah so this
position he already had against Nakamura
and g5 is one of the engines top
suggestions it's not something that's no
computer does come up with if you
analyze this position with an engine you
will see the move that it is there let's
say in the position and I don't know
maybe I'm having wrong expectations
there but I think I'm if he is some kind
of after the game that you played
against Nakamura or even before that you
probably should should check what's
going on and if that move is popping up
I don't know I would probably feel
inclined to check it because it looks
very weird and difficult to face over
the world yeah I wouldn't expect that
move to be there let's say and if the
computer tells me it is there it is
existing that is something serious then
probably it make sense to get to study
it a bit but it doesn't seem to be the
case is really seem to be genuinely
surprised by it okay it happened g5 and
yeah what did cosplay he took it yeah
and I sent out to 30 minutes yeah to
pile of place 95 that is one point you
now have the e5 square for the night
temporarily you attack that bishop so
ambition went back by the way instead of
ninety-five they also what's the move
see takes be five which is leading to
somewhat also somewhat crazy
complications but I understand 195 was
chose it's a little bit easier to to
contemplate in them come back up in
comparison yeah its opposite this is all
so crazy I g45 teex 95 is some line that
the computer is giving and here I mean
this looks like complete craziness it's
a very very M I guess unsettling feeling
if someone springs g5 upon you
and you have to work it out over the
board knowing that the other side will
have check that with engines beforehand
okay 95 we should be to bishop f1 was
also possible but there should be two
certainly make some sense and now like
captured yeah very interesting position
very unconventional the pawn on c4 is
quite an yeah quite a funny fellow here
for Hope like it it makes sure that
there is some control yeah that g4s not
happening easily and they were securing
that night yeah white now has a couple
of interesting options um what
contemplate is interesting but maybe not
not the best move he went night a three
that has some logic of course white
wants to take on c4 with the night room
very sensible looking move there were
some alternatives as I as I mentioned um
something that that comes to mind is to
take on Sephora using a 94 Queen a form
however if you look at this Knight takes
Queen s197 chicks and 95 again you see
that this probably didn't lead to much a
queen maybe to c3 not quite sure and
Ruby g8 and as weird as it looks black
seems to have a good position Bishop g7
is coming he's got two bishops and well
it looks a bit crummy blacks position
but what is what about white sir that's
all so weird that is all back here it
hasn't developed the queen is out
somewhere it's just it did it's rather
weird but black had some things going
for him this bishop will be very strong
on g7 and D for the potential
potentially very strong outpost for you
for your Nigel 96-94 for example yeah so
Bishop c4 wasn't a good idea but I think
what is a good idea is nine f3 this is
um probably rather strong move um I am
while preparing for for this video I am
I came across some some some brief
analysis
here by alejandro ramirez the American
Grandmaster and he recommended that move
I checked a little bit myself and it
seems to be pretty good actually it has
some logic if I've is the rather it's a
strongest piece that black has so we're
going to try to get rid of that and
something like Nigeria bishop f3 already
feels uncomfortable why tens untangled a
little bit there and he has some very
yeah either will pick up this pawn I
will play d3 to get full development and
all in all this feels like a huge gain
from whether you five is a is a threat
as well so this is probably the more
interesting move takes Teague's and now
'if I've is interesting yeah white opens
up the position and after all he is a
bit better developed yeah like I only
headset knock it out um this feels like
a very very interesting and sharp
position which probably is favoring
right a little bit yeah we don't know
what to follow and install it that would
have been probably the critical test of
the whole thing however it is an
interesting gamble if you g five is the
move that really will shock your
opponent if you have not ever seen it
and it probably is exactly what happened
Carla didn't know of the movement had to
figure it out over the board and then
it's difficult to hit upon those
critical continuations um yeah how does
this continue one thing that is not
working is this check nice the line this
is hanging as usual combinations are
possible if there's some kind of
disturbance off of harmony in the
opponent's position right here there are
pins going on and unprotected pieces um
black probably I mean he can probably
take but he has to do something else now
maybe move the Queen on here owns the
night in the first place it is a very
dangerous initiative really is what some
development advantage is quite quite
serious yeah as I said car
didn't go for that he went night a three
he probably had the the coming
continuation in mind Luke g8 attacking
that night it is really unprotected on
25 because the team point is they're
back home and yeah and what did cards do
he ignored it interestingly enough he
played 90 key for that was probably his
idea sacrificing a piece again after a
long thing um there were alternatives
you did not need to sacrifice yet um the
engines give the move d3 which is well
probably not what you what you have
dreamt up in the first place but it is
okay it is really okay blackville take a
guess and Bishop takes and well this is
equal material right this is we don't
have to sacrifice a pc or anything it's
equal material and blacks position is
still not easy to handle with the King
in the middle and I know I think I think
why is perfectly okay here the computer
gifts and something like this h6 driving
the night back and then it wants to
Teague and play d5 um yeah and I think
white is totally okay yeah why why is
something then is it is it bad you know
I don't I don't really think so I think
white can white can play that position
without any any huge problem even even
the endgame when black has got two
bishops seems fairly okay to me I mean
whites pawn structure is basically
perfect and black has for porn islands
so I mean that that should be at least
equal for what I mean at least equal it
is prob it's okay right it's why it will
not be better here um because while the
mission parents such a big asset in that
open position that it's probably
equalling it's probably probably equal
ish because black because of the pawns
will probably lose some porn at some
point and he will have great
compensation with its bishops that's the
most likely scenario that's going to
happen later on but it's okay for white
nothing wrong with it I think maybe one
ish
was that that Carson definitely wanted
to win that game and he probably
underestimated something that that he M
that he calculated he also have to see
the overall standings of the event with
cars and wanting to catch up and the
history between the two players in the
in the first lack of that grandchester
cards and lost the first round game
against a part of out of the completely
winning position because he wasn't aware
of the somewhat weird time control a
very a strange incident that was of
course I'm yeah I mean you probably
heard of it or read about it so this is
also an interesting little fact that
maybe this also yeah provoked him let's
say to play a play that in that shop way
um but it's I mean those psychological
things are interesting but he probably
just didn't see something right yeah you
had some kind of miss fair valuation
because it's really not working working
great okay it took on see form like took
that and okay don't forget that night is
hanging um taking on g5 isn't a good
idea because of T FOIA that's a double
attack in essence so not not great take
cm and yeah now the problem is wide
cannot just recapture and okay if he
does then here there's really no
compensation for the piece absolutely
nothing Saudi for that was his idea so
covering this attacking this so black
has to react to this and have to pester
probably move the night there are no
great alternatives 9 p-6 looks very
logical and now Bishop h5 this was
probably carden's idea and somewhere
around here he probably um yeah miss has
miscalculated misjudged something and by
the way the engine or the engines I
looked at this with multiple and they
suggest this continuation check check
and only give white only give black a
very small plus like 0.4 something which
I found pretty surprising I mean I
understand that blacks pawn structure is
bad but white only has two pawns and I
think with excellent technical play
black black we should win this I
probably will win this um I'm a bit
surprised about the about the engines
evaluation here um and this is also
something then white definitely does not
want to play because you know that
you're completely playing for two
results and the witness not one of them
and from there to results and loss is
the most likely so this is you don't go
into an endgame a piece down here so
it's very understandable that cheap why
am I not and this is not reacting let me
check I know it does okay so he didn't
do that he played Bishop h5 like has to
take of course it was hanging Queen
takes threatening that crushing check on
f7 black hands to play rook g 6o g seven
um I think actually that Luke g6 um
which was not played but Apollo and it
might have been a little bit stronger
but i don't know i don't know if it's a
huge difference rook g6 and that maybe
maybe a bit stronger one line that that
comes to mind T is Queen h7 Luke g7
queen age 8 and now the capture on d4
yeah now it is some difficult to suggest
something better than night h7 getting
some material back wyd renea doesn't
have any particularly great idea I mean
what what other movie if you play
something and it's even Nazi for coming
yeah you're really out of moves
basically okay you have to get something
back yeah now black would just give the
exchange back and now plays I either the
night over to the King side or even play
five this is an excellent position for
black yeah we have to check the material
five points for black 64 white so white
is got look and one point against two
minor pieces this is quite often not so
bad for the rook but in this particular
case I think black is much much better
because his strong points in the center
he has very good positions for his
pieces especially Bishop on e6 will be
very nicely anchored black has two
bishops and which is very important part
of whites pawns are these here and you
cannot just push them forward in front
of your king so very often the big
deciding factor in that rook and pawn
against minor pieces is what are the
pawns doing if they if they get into
motion and get running and quite often
rook and pawn is pretty good but here
this is not the case Black is also
active and we get more active there
should be six rook c8 97-95 those kind
of ideas that really is great for black
so this was maybe a line that could have
happened after Luke g6 and probably also
yeah a clearer way of showing that
causes p sacrifice was not really
working to part of page rook g7 however
and clearly he is now thinking is this
taking time night h7 it's difficult to
suggest anything else you have to reduce
move to get something back so it takes
and now to power plant a rather strange
move I think it's not the most natural
move that comes to mind um then the
easiest solution here was to to take on
h7 just to give that back or I'll give
it back now give something back that
same and take hear that that looks like
a pretty good position which is actually
quite similar to the one that we have
seen before yeah it's a very comparable
structure and the other line that was
coming from Luke g6 black was a tempo up
and head if I've in already here this
wide smooth um
I think blackest is better here as well
so it's not I mean tempe I'm point here
but still the the long-term factors are
pretty pretty significant and think
black has a pretty sizable advantage
ship but he didn't do that he played the
move and I said Queen to d7 by the way
Bishop g4 is also almost was interesting
to check but let's look at what happened
a queen d 7 it seems by the way that
after Queen d7 cancer now had an
opportunity to get a somewhat decent
game again difficult to play stuff but
he had a good continuation he took on c5
which is right black recaptured and now
I think he should have played 9 f8 the
most obvious move um the thing is he
probably saw that this is okay for him
but he probably misjudged the the
continuation that he played because here
well what what should like do the idea
obviously was to play Queen age three
here yeah black cannot capture this is
Sam the hard way to checkmate lose the
game very quickly and completely first
made so he wouldn't played this and
threatening made on g2 so nothing else y
tends to take Bishop takes g3 and a very
strange position now if black takes on a
fade bishop age six actually leads to
something where I'd rather be white yeah
this is now rook and two parts were
these two minor pieces and the minor
pieces are not very well coordinated at
the moment yeah night on b6 hmm doesn't
really i mean the night is not one
default let's say that that would be an
entirely different story besides 94
would have folks on a three and so on
but just the night doesn't have a great
great square and here black is in
trouble definitely and this is rather
good for white so black will probably
not take that night but play something
else and then we have a situation to her
why these two pawns up for the moment
but the night is strapped yeah it cannot
get out it doesn't get anywhere anytime
soon so totally strange position and um
yeah I don't know I think the only
reason why I cards might have avoided it
because he definitely saw that I mean
it's a pretty simple line is that he
probably thought that his moves are
stronger which is not the case in fact
this seems to be losing but that's the
only explanation sometimes it's not that
they em if they make a mistake it's not
that they don't see the other line and
Knight f8 is the most normal move ever
so its of course cards has seen that but
he probably thought that he five would
be stronger and aunt he has some
misjudged something here I did not the
broadcast them was so I watched the
broadcast up till the end of the games
and i'm not sure if they had any
statements and afterwards so i cannot
really tell what Calvin said if he had a
statement term but yeah I wanted to go
to bed at some time this is also why
this video is coming relatively late
then it's a bit of an unlucky time for
that event it's the games normally end
at midnight German time and well
sometime I might manage to make a video
right after that and release it but in
most cases i will do it in the morning
on the following day like now so II five
what what now um Quincy six that's
pretty obvious right this is not what
Carlton could have missed threatening
mate and you never miss this this kind
of moose um yeah and now it's already
not so clear what you want you to yeah
Knight f6 this is a flashy looking move
intending to check to to go for this
with unclear consequences may be why
this even even better but it's
unimportant Black has king the eight and
this is leading nowhere yeah you can
give a check if you like and black
escape he's just running yeah and
ultimately this is hanging and there's
made on g2 it's a rather simple win even
so Knight f6 is not working at all um he
actually went with f3 Bishop g5 is move
that the computer points out but that is
ultimately also not going to lead to
much black can even consider just to go
back and make himself ready to take on
f8 with the rook yeah if what decides to
take on a fade um Jeff that's also not
great so f3 once was played at the end
Queen g6 the strong move again made and
the Queen and I really I really don't
know what what did cards an overlooked
here I don't know he went nine f6 check
and King e8 yeah maybe he really didn't
really consider kinky eight I don't know
I really don't know um if black takes
and which we should check it check then
again this continuation is not clear at
all absolutely not but King d8 it's just
it's just saying okay I move the king
your queen is kind of a checked here you
cannot move your night because of that
and if you have to tread Queens I'm a
piece up and this is what happened yeah
right now has to train our just six days
simply no other move rook takes Knight
back and now we caught an end game with
black being a piss-up 42 points and in
still not um super trivial task I mean I
can easily see myself I don't know
screwing this up with some with some
stupid moves but with good technical
play and and precise calculation it
should be a win for black and the pool
of desert does a good job here we
shouldn't forget that yeah they both
didn't have that much
time 11 minutes for Carlin 17 or 18 here
for photo part of Bishop d7 is a good
active move not defending passively here
that pawn white cannot take any way
because of Bishop f3 so each form tried
to use that part's rook c8 covering c 5
h 5 and went back okay push up to 294
bishops III a funny line that that you
can yeah that that that might happen if
black is completely blind is this rook
t1 yeah night be true with about million
question marks championship a5 check
King 896 check that's funny right it
takes she takes Bishop e7 only move
rookie selfshot and Rudy d7 and white
we're quite clearly is winning yeah
maybe if you give the company of time it
probably show a checkmate good yeah but
ok that's completely unnecessary after a
rooty one of course black will just take
that Bishop legs and then then here you
know again if 95 there's Bishop f3 and
black is crashing through yeah bishops
III was played Bishop h6 activating that
Bishop very nicely played check book you
one yeah and the only interesting little
point is is coming up black is now
activating this Bishop there to be five
lining up on that diagonal many looks
there okay rook you one back yeah now
car the plate night f2 which is a
mistake but it is really not that
important anymore because well time goes
down to one minute something and well
the position was lost and it doesn't
alter the whole thing very much but
should be five is a nice little shot
here by two part of exposing that Bishop
so if what did he play actually now
who I am ok this should be five this
Bishop f3 and those are lined up very
nicely so I'm a win route de one root G
check king of one another funny point
group g five tanks tanks everything hang
sir it's it it's really funny blackest
black is completely winning here as this
was played takes him and king of it and
now black has just won one additional
point in the process right now it's just
one point for a piece and I think under
normal circumstances he would resign but
cards and as you see a he had he had two
seconds they play without do they play
without increment I think they do right
looks like it I didn't check actually
what the time control is but he was
simply too sure very short on time and
was just blitzing out some stuff and
then resigned as it sometimes happens
you really as you say you don't have I
didn't have time to resign let's say
yeah what do what to take from this game
very important win obviously for the
part of who starts with a win with the
black pieces against the world champion
and Carlton um still seems to be a
little bit off after his performance in
Norway chess about him it's about two
months ago right yeah about two months
ago um yeah things that surprised me a
little bit was that um he didn't know of
the move g5 I don't know maybe and it's
a wrong wrong idea that I have there but
I was thinking if you if you recheck or
if you do a post-game analysis let's say
of your game so like it certainly does I
thought then it would have popped up and
it it's easily imaginable that the thing
is the the top GM they look for those
kind of moves those weird looking moves
that are kind of
unconventional but they are playable and
they can pre they can check it before
the game with computers so they can
spring a surprise and they have superior
knowledge in that very very limited area
yeah where they have the information
advantage and this is why I was thinking
that when you do this after the game
against nakamura if you do a post game
um check and this move pops up that you
would to check it a little bit and see
what the best continuation is but it
obviously didn't happen um yeah and then
we came to this situation where Carlton
was going for that piece sacrifice then
ultimately does not seem to work however
he got a second chance here by two part
off when he played Queen d7 after which
9 f8 seems to have her led to yeah
immensely unclear consequences that
weird that we had endgame that we that
we have seen I'm sorry first the caption
that that that strange game where black
is probably not taking that night and I
have no idea what how to assess that the
engines give equal which is completely
useless yeah it's just an immensely
unconventional position but it didn't
take that opportunity which this is
really surprising me that that he was
surprising or surprised in the opening
okay this can happen and it happened
before and and to everybody yeah it's
nothing out of the ordinary but that he
did not go for that um but went for if
I'm sorry that was the wrong button went
for that a five moves and this is really
not working at all I mean completely not
that is surprising and as I said I don't
know what exactly he he missed it must
be some kind of miscalculation it's a
purely purely calculation heavy position
it's not something where where long-term
judgment plays a role which is certainly
favorite Apollo in that set up because
if they get some long-term planning a
game
Carson would probably win almost all of
them as it happened before he has a
fantastic score against the part of
especially evidence that kind of slow is
maneuvering game ok I hope you enjoyed
the coverage of that game I'm going to
briefly um give you a summary of the
other games what happened so there were
all our games were decisive so nekomura
be darned um in a nice game um are not
basically made and made a huge mistake
when when time was ticking down a little
bit but a good game I like him right and
really had some pressure was poking
around a little bit and won a deserved
game very nice victory for american
number one um then um Levon Aronian had
wide against carwin and won a very very
nice game that I also could have covered
that was the second game that I
seriously considered to cover but
because of the other said general
sporting importance i went for cards and
to follow very interesting game Caruana
played a very played in a very sharp way
out of a Queens gambit declined with
black which you don't see that often but
Aronian played a very imaginative nice
attack and and one in good style I
really hope that he gets back to his
former former self and he really am such
a great player and it was some bad or
awful to see him struggling in recent
events so maybe he's getting back to a
good shape then Geary won a game a nice
game against greece shocked very shocked
yeah had to had problems for a while
already and then time trouble was was
totally killing him so very good win by
geary and then we had wesley soul
playing wide against maxima Sheila graph
Westley so is the organizers pick in
that event is not a regular on the chest
to him mostly because it was the chester
was compiled when souls rating was still
a little bit lower um anyway in in that
game where
so funny enough he um yeah he um played
a very early porn rep that it's known to
be questionable from from all very old
games one game by backup of actually
from the 70s and he had nothing to show
I mean no improvement nothing invested i
graph had a great compensation and won a
nice game so it was a bit a bit
mysterious what happened there maybe
wester so really didn't know that game
Tata with white was a scalp or from 1970
something um thing is when I saw that
game and I didn't have any commentary it
struck me like hmm I kind of know that
but I didn't I couldn't really piece it
together that it was tart I Karpov okay
so i hope you enjoyed that video i'll be
covering the next rounds as well um one
round actually i'm covering completely a
completely a live move by move for the
ISS see if you're an ICC member i'll be
doing a live stream on on thursday just
for the members now you cannot watch
free on to it chef to join Isis you to
do that okay well thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow with the second
route bye